we have a coronavirus stimulus deal that
has finally been reached and as some of
you might have heard on my live streams
everyday there's like three proposals
floated and maybe it's going to happen
maybe it's not and then it gets canceled
or replaced with something else so
because we've all along if I had talked
about every possible deal the entire
show would have been just possible deals
that didn't become a reality we just
decided we're going to wait and then
we'll discuss the deal once it's
actually done the priorities for me are
we've got to bail people out people with
bills people with expenses people who
need money and may no longer have a job
we've got to do something about small
business very very important because a
lot of small businesses can't weather
this I'm talking to small business
owners all the time in my neighborhood
and other neighborhoods in Boston who
say you know I can make 30 percent of
what I was making before but the problem
is my rent is 40 percent so I need
something I need some kind of bridge to
get me there
and you want to provide capital
strategically to reduce interruptions of
different kinds prevent the unemployment
rate from exploding as much as it would
without some incentive for small
businesses to keep people on etc this is
the largest stimulus package in American
history now a stimulus package the
concept of a stimulus package is it's a
Keynesian idea the idea being government
spending can lessen the severity of a
recession stimulate the economy boost
employment boost spending that's the
framework it's a Keynesian framework
we're talking about this deal was
reached just hours ago around 1:30 a.m.
Eastern Time
very early this morning here is
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell announcing it at last we have
a deal after days of intense discussions
the Senate has reached a bipartisan
agreement on a historic relief package
for this pandemic it will rush new
resources onto the front lines of our
nation's health care fight and it will
inject trillions of dollars of cash into
the economy as fast as possible as you
can tell there Mitch McConnell just
overwhelmed with ammo
over this historic deal so what's in it
some of the details are still being
worked out some of the language is still
being written as of as of this second
but here's what we have so far it'll be
a two trillion dollar stimulus package
people individuals earning up to $75,000
in income will get a $1200 one-time
check couples double the money for
double the income limit $2,400 if as a
couple you earn up to a hundred and
fifty thousand you get an additional
five hundred dollars per child based on
what we saw an hour ago against some of
the final details may change the $1,200
check starts to phase out as you
approach 99 thousand dollars in income
as an individual or a hundred
ninety-eight thousand as a couple and
once you get to that level 99 K per
person you lose the twelve you lose all
the money unit you get zero after that
point unemployment insurance will be
expanded to include people that are
furloughed gig workers freelancers right
people that would not normally qualify
for unemployment insurance they will
also be adding and this is one of the
things that's a probably but we don't
know for sure yet it looks like they're
going to increase the unemployment
payments by 600 bucks a week for four
months above the state base different
states unemployment insurance is
state-based so the benefit in
Massachusetts may be different from the
benefit in Florida or in California
that'll be up to buy six hundred bucks a
week by the federal government there
will be an employee retention tax credit
for businesses to keep people on so
we've seen two versions between 25 and
50 billion dollars for passenger
airlines between 4 and 8 billion for
cargo airlines 17 billion for companies
determined to be important to national
security the details of course still
remain to be determined they're roughly
500 billion dollars in a corporate
liquidity program these would be loans
to businesses through banks very
important to understand that would be
through banks and then another three
hundred sixty seven billion roughly
through a small business loan program
through the small business its
association 30 billion in education
funding 25 bill
in transit funding so this is the bulk
of it now there's a question about the
income limit on the $1,200 check is 75 K
what's the process and verification of
that if it's based on 2019 income a lot
of people haven't filed their 2019 tax
returns so what happens there we don't
know there's the idea that you would use
2018 income if you've not yet filed your
2019 tax return excuse me could that be
gamed in some way we don't know but this
is part of the the detail that still
needs to be worked out another question
is how does this impact self-employed
people there are some other specifics
that need to be sorted out but it's
finally happening it's happening far too
late it's happening after a lot of
personal financial damage has already
happened to people who have been laid
off for one week two weeks even longer
in some cases truck Schumer Senate
Minority Leader says that trumps
businesses will not be eligible for any
of this stuff that's an assertion from
Chuck Schumer I've not yet seen any
language that makes that clear this is
the framework we have so far in the
background of all this Donald Trump
increase increasingly wants to reopen
everything or close to everything on
Easter Sunday April 12th I want to talk
about that next and we'll be doing a
sort of deeper dive into that a little
bit later in the program check this out
the first 500 people who see this video
and go to david pakman.com slash skill
will get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it
we should allow ourselves a little time
every week to either get creative keep
your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with Skillshare you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video